hello believes nation I started - did
you know series to help us understand
some of our favorite entrepreneurs a
little bit more what makes them tick
some of the fun things have happened in
their life until today we're going to
look at 9 surprising facts about Bill
Gates fact number one when he was 13
years old he programmed the schedule for
his school and put all the girls that he
liked in his class yeah computers came
along when I was 13 and they kind of
intimidated the teacher so I and a few
others were viewed as the computer
experts and they were nice enough to let
us do the scheduling of the different
classes so I could decide you know which
girls were in my class I had lots of
great girls my class I didn't talk to
them much but they were there but I mean
you started a high point there from then
on bill it's all downhill hi you're 13
years old you're manipulating there that
girl from your class that's like a dream
no I it's great privilege hate learning
science she'll be amazed on your way
fact number two as a teen at Lakeside
prep school he wrote his first computer
program on a general electric computer
it was a version of tic-tac-toe where
you could play against the computer one
of the first things I learned was how to
write a program to play tic-tac-toe and
that's why if statements to say ok if
the other person must win go ahead and
block that spot fact number 3 he reads
50 books a year and once he starts one
he has to finish it I don't let myself
start a book that I'm not going to
finish
you know when you're reading you have to
be careful that you really are
concentrated particularly if it's a
non-fiction book are you taking the new
knowledge and sort of attaching to
knowledge you have for me taking notes
helps make sure that I'm really thinking
hard about what about looks in there
if I disagree with it look sometimes it
takes a long time to read the book
because I'm striking so much and the
margin it's actually kind of frustrating
oh please say something I agree with
like and get through to the end of this
book so there's this one it's a picture
of a public internet chess but I'm
trying to decide if I structure on top
because I watch the movie the end of the
tour I loved it David Foster Wallace
comes across as a super in 15 broad
thinking in person if the book was like
two or three hundred page book there's
no doubt as soon as I watched that movie
I died in but it's quite lost and
complicated and you know I don't want to
make an exception it's my rule to to get
to the end over time I will make the
switch but when I'm sitting there at
night reading often a paper magazine or
the book
I'm used to that it's ridiculous because
I care I have old both days that goes on
like Chris with me and its voluminous
and antiquated after reading books like
these you'd want to be sitting down for
an hour at a time because otherwise just
getting your mind around okay what was I
reading is not the kind of thing you can
prove five minutes here 10 minutes there
magazine articles fit are short YouTube
videos get into those little slots and
so you know every night I'm reading a
little over an hour
and so I can take my crime vocal make
some progress fact number four
despite his interest in artificial
intelligence he's in the camp of those
that are concerned about the power of
super intelligence theoretical physicist
Stephen Hawking whom I'm sure you know
warned this week that technology could
end up ending humanity at some point do
you share that apocalyptic view of
technology well I think it's something
that it's not going to happen overnight
I do think we have to worry about it I
don't think its inherent that as we
create super intelligence that it will
necessarily always have the same goals
in mind that we do you know humans don't
always have the same goal with other
humans so who gets control of the
technology how is it built in I don't
think there's a need to panic but I
think the dialogue along those levels
the people who say that let's not worry
at all I don't agree with that fact
number five for years he used to fly
coach when he travelled by air but in
1997 decided to buy his own plane which
he calls his one true extravagance well
certainly the greatest extravagance is
that I got out of them I travel I often
go by use a private plane and that is
very extravagant you're just talking
that can stop until I waited I thought
that was kind of a decadent thing but
then when I started traveling to Africa
in Asia a lot I gave in on that you do
it you enjoy that now yeah you enjoy
that no it's a luxury it's my one true
extravagant
fact number six in 1994 he purchased the
Codex light dessert which was a
collection of writings by Leonardo da
Vinci for thirty point eight million
dollars when Donna was a truly meek
person in terms of his curiosity no one
could have such broad range of knowledge
today there's just too much to know well
it was very surreal I went to the
auctions first major auction I'd ever
been to this by virtue of the fact I was
an invited player because I wrote a very
short introduction to the catalog and
you go and there's this rather small
auction room and there are people
bidding and it's over I don't know how
long it took nothing flat the people on
the telephone and their people present
and it's over it's sold for over 30
million dollars nobody knows who bought
it so what he posed who bought it that
evening well there's a number of milk
books of Leonardo's that are are
preserved they think this is quite a few
others that weren't preserves this
particular notebook was owned by the
Earl right sister and then was bought by
an American he made a lot of mistakes
about did he really pay for it properly
and so it had to be auctioned I bid for
it over the phone and I didn't want
people to know who I was and when I grew
up I read a lot about history and
particularly history of science you know
scientists seem interesting I mean the
idea that one person could figure
something out
that nobody else understood and then
explain it to other people and that idea
that they just what did they do just
concentrate or how did they how did they
do that and there's a lot of fascinating
figures in the history of science even
some recent scientists I think are quite
incredible but Leonardo to me was sort
of the most interesting he wandered
around as a kid because at that time you
were either sort of a noble person who
went to school
or you were somebody who worked on the
farm and because he was the son of a
nobleman but not by that in his life he
was in a strange category he that's why
I definitely have a last name his name
Leonardo da Vinci just means Leonardo of
the town that he grew up in which was
Vincey but everybody's always debated a
little bit which do you think of him
more as a scientist or an artist he
probably contributed more to science
than the art because of the notebook
fact number seven like a lot of other
successful tech entrepreneurs he is a
college dropout in 1975 he dropped out
of Harvard University to focus on
Microsoft whole time you went to Harvard
and you dropped out have you ever
thought how your life could be better
off if you had gotten your Harvard
degree well I I'm a weird dropout
because I take college courses all the
time I love learning company courses and
things so I love being a student and
there were smart people around and you
know they fed you and they gave you
these nice grades that made you feel
smart so I I feel it was unfortunate
that I didn't get to stay there but I
don't think I missed any knowledge
because you know whatever I needed to
learn I would I was still in a learning
mode sock number eight in the early days
of Microsoft they said that he was a
nightmare bot and your early days you
described yourself as a nightmare book
with your words not mine and with your
work at work ethic that's very different
to everybody else's I was fanatical in
my 20s
helping Microsoft lead the way in
software was the only thing that I
really focused on so you know I worked
weekends I didn't believe in vacation
and so I I really pushed people to work
hard you can I was still learning how to
manage people particularly the different
skill sets the salespeople the
accounting people uh and so you know I I
fortunately I think I'm a little bit
better now
that's ridiculous oh now I'm not gonna
say no no no somebody creepy no they
just not thankfully there's no way that
I've never understood never understood
the first thing about this
he's certainly passionate and how do I
interpret that somebody shouts yeah
there are times of course there are
times he shouts I think that as he's
grown older that the ratio of shouting
to non shouting has tremendously
decreased and fact number nine despite
his immense wealth gates said he's only
given his children ten million dollars
in inheritance which is a small portion
of it's 80 plus a billion net worth
everybody who's wealthy who has children
has to deal with how do you train your
children to live with the wealth how
much do you give them and how do you get
them involved in philanthropies well our
kids are young enough that the key focus
is helping them you know enjoy learning
get a great education all of them will
pick careers that aren't related to
software philanthropy they will strike
out in their own direction and be great
you know in their own way whatever it is
they pick to do so we've chosen that
they'll have enough wealth that they'll
never be poor or anything but we're not
going to take billions of dollars and
have that defined their life to the vast
majority of the wealth is dedicated to
the foundation thank you guys so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed this did
you know series I'd love to know what
did you think this is one of the series
that is on the bubble for us who keeps
doing it shooing not should we kill it
and put something else in I'd love to
get your feedback leave it in the
comments below to let me know what you
think finally I want to give a quick
shout out to Michael Johnson Michael
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and posting my
picture on Instagram I love it min and I
appreciate the support so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon